-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope everyone's
doing well tonight
and I cannot stress enough
to everybody here
this is an office building.
[ Laughter ]
People are trying
to get work done.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to the news.
During his rally
over the weekend,
former President Trump endorsed
88-year-old
Senator Chuck Grassley
for reelection.
"Who the hell is
Chuck Grassley?"
said Chuck Grassley.
[ Laughter ]
Today was
Indigenous Peoples' Day.
Now, of course, some people
still call it Columbus Day
and, to those people, I say,
how you getting back to Jersey?
[ Laughter and applause ]
PATH train?
[ Laughter ]
In her new book,
ex-White House Press Secretary
Stephanie Grisham
called Republican
Senator Lindsey Graham
"Senator Freeloader,"
as opposed to Trump,
who doesn't call him at all.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview --
Well, you know...
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
the CEO of Airbnb said
that the largest risk
to Big Tech is
that "the world is rooting
against them."
Luckily, they can't hear it
from space.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
the Saudi royal family
gave former President Trump
three robes made
with white tiger and cheetah fur
that turned out to be fake.
Come on, you guys,
even Trump knows
that cheetahs
don't look like this --
[ Laughter ]
The Katmai National Park
in Alaska
recently concluded online voting
in its so-called Fat Bear Week
and a 25-year-old bear named
Otis won for the fourth time.
Or, more accurately,
a bear in Alaska
is being cyberbullied.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Congratulations, Otis."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
20% of Americans say
they have pretended
to be bad at a task
so they wouldn't have
to do it again.
So maybe that's
what the Mets are up to.
One for the crew.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Not going to forget you guys.
You were there for me
during the lean times.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The Boston Marathon
was held today.
It's the only marathon that
starts with someone yelling --
[ Boston accent ]
Cops are here!
[ Cheer, laughter,
and applause ]
And, finally,
two men from the Soloman Islands
were recently rescued
after spending 29 days
lost at sea,
living off only oranges,
coconuts, rain water,
and the third guy.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
Oh.
Oh, Ian, oh, Ian's so happy
the groans are back.
[ Laughter ]
That's what Ian wants to hear
when he writes a joke like that.
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue!